bless her I just apologize really where
the and this is did I screw up by Tyler
I own this yet from Cambridge so my
problem is I forgot my best friend's
birthday I hadn't been on Facebook that
day and I just literally forgot I sent
her an apology text under present but
she's just not forgiving me
I screw up I actually hate when friends
do that yeah yeah because it's like they
do a power trip and if you're a real
real friend it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter and having is an accident and
it's not intentional and like if you're
a real friend you'd be like that's cool
like let's do our own celebration let's
do our own I've almost done that before
actually I am I really a catch myself I
was like why am i dating
hold it off but I had a peck well well
give him something nice some nice
combines real name gonna need some mints
for a few weeks
yeah yeah I just apologize really
[Laughter]
apology well
you get Chi screw up I mean for him
here's the thing I don't know if I'm
being petty but my coworker is most
disgusting eater ever it's so loudly and
with her mouth open
oh it's got to the point where literally
makes me feel physically sick like I
have to leave the office every day about
12:00 and my bosses start asking where
I'm going and I had to tell him and
here's the thing he confronted her in
front of everyone she started crying I
feel so bad did I screw up it's miss
lavinia is what it's called when you
have a reaction to people eating with
their mouths open yeah I have that I
hate when people like it drives me nuts
it gets me angry
miss Athenians wow there's a term for
the term for did you learn something new
every day
[Laughter]
your boss however did after I kissed an
ex-boyfriend here was her childhood see
out and I've had it sold her the way
I've been got to have my her friends and
she confronted me and because I was so
nervous I just denied it was for heinous
crime that's like a sisterhood line that
you just shouldn't cross oh is it love
or is it just a situation I think it was
just a situation they should probably
add a few times and just slipped right
in
[Laughter]
hi I'm Rachel from Derbyshire I have a
problem as I absolutely hate and baby
showers oh let me not use this filter to
disguise her we can see you Rachel they
look real cute we can say you I'm not
very good with kids and also don't
have that much time to myself at the
moment so my friends having a baby
shower and I just really didn't want to
go so I told her the reasons why that I
don't really like kids and but rather do
loads more stuff myself at the moment oh
I told of those reasons and now she
won't talk to me did I screw up it's not
about not being truthful be honest but
you don't have to say I'd rather do
something else than be with kids you
don't just say you know I'm sorry I
can't make it you know yeah so karma
it's saying just lie don't tell the part
about not like that's your friend and
they're about to have a kid you don't
want to tell them I don't like kids
there's gonna be disconnecting your
friendship I think least you won't have
to babysit that's true thank you screw
that
okay I've really thought about my
stepfather he's so obnoxious and rude
and three on answer he makes my mum
miserable and she doesn't even realize
that I keep buying their little gifts
but I'm stealing fibers here and there
from his audits a funder he hasn't been
eyes yet bees now actually acting really
suspicious around me I don't know if I'm
being paranoid but I just want my mother
to be happy
did I screw up I mean you stole how old
is she though cuz she looks like a
little baby hair but she's probably
grown enough to have her own money to
buy five quid and sweets and flowers she
straight it and steal it from this
dude's wallet from yo man and he's
paranoid for a reason babe I just don't
think you should steal in general
definitely screwed up and I know cuz she
make loads snide remarks me and I'm you
today we're in the kitchen Arun and she
actually said to me that's been
questionable my way where is the world
of string around
I just caught the end of that and then
this is what she said it was I think
it's better to rise above I think that
it wasn't a very nice comment it was
very rude like you said but I think
you've chosen different words to express
your emotions so maybe the f off I think
those are really strong words yeah it's
the mom like you still want to have
respect in to rise above to be like
that's below me words can be very
hurtful and the same token I'm sorry for
saying choice of words but we feel you
hi Tyler its Jessica from Yorkshire so I
hate my boss really don't get along with
her and the other day I put some
slightly off milk into a tea and so
she's been off sick for the last few
days and I do feel bit bad about it
apparently she's got food poisoning did
I screw up yeah have you say 9 to 5 the
musical know there's the whole stories
about like poisoning the boss like
basically yeah yeah that's not good
there's a bit of a screw up there no no
evil I think she's screwed up and that
was did I screw up for Tyler I thought
you were staring at me but really you
were just staring at my mic like going
is that gonna fall off
[Music]
[Applause]
you